Ja, aber gut, vielleicht nochmal etwas einfacher eingestiegen. Ja, wir haben also ein Gerät, die einfachste Stufe ist der Imseacatcher. Wir bringen diese Identität der Telefone in Erfahrung. So und was man da aber zunächst sieht, sind nur die Einbuchversuche der Telefone. Ja, sein Einbuchversuch. Und dann kann ich als derjenige, der sozusagen diese falsche Basisstation kontrolliert, respektive die Software, die das tut, kann ich sagen, den schicke ich mal wieder zurück aufs normale Netz, den will ich gar nicht. Oder ich kann sagen, hey, das ist ja mein Target, den lasse ich jetzt mal rein in meine Zelle. Und dadurch kann man dann eben so selektive Sachen machen. Und wenn jetzt das Telefon einer Person in meiner falschen Basisstation eingebucht ist, dann kann ich diese ganzen Angriffe machen, die Andy beschrieben hat. Also mit ausgehende Angriffe woanders hin umleiten oder SMS schicken, die gar nicht stimmen. Oder was weiß ich, da kommt eine eingehende SMS an und da steht dann drin Treffpunkt, diese Uhrzeit, dieser Ort. Und dann schreibe ich halt eine andere Uhrzeit in einen anderen Ort rein, um den irgendwie da abzugreifen oder so. Also das sind halt alles Möglichkeiten, die man da hat ab dem Punkt, wenn man dann solche Main-in-the-Mittel-Angriffe erfährt. Da hat man dann nicht nur die falsche Basisstation, sondern man hat dann auch noch ein falsches Telefon sozusagen, was dann gegenüber dem echten Netz sich wie das Telefon des angegriffenen verhält.
Und im Fall Dresden lässt sich nicht ausschießen, dass die Polizei eben ein solches Gerät eingesetzt hat, einfach mit der Konfiguration alle im SIS reinzulassen und auch entsprechend passiv dann, wenn man die einmal identifiziert hat, die Verkehrsdaten aus der Luft abzugreifen.
Das geht eben auch. Da gibt es eine Aussage dazu, meines Wissens nach im Sächsischen Landtag wurde, ich weiß nicht mehr wer es war, aber seitens der Polizei oder des entsprechenden Innenministeriums usw. wurde bestätigt, dass ein Imsycatcher eingesetzt wurde auch. Zunächst wurde es bestritten, so wie in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Ja, zunächst über Überwachung, wir haben noch nicht überwacht. Und dann sind es irgendwie ein paar Hundert, ein paar Tausend, ein paar Zehn Tausend, ein paar Hunderttausend Datensätze und auch Leute. Dann sagt man, oh man war ja selber überrascht von der Menge der Datensätze, die eigentlich angefallen sind. Es ist ja auch völlig unlogisch, das ist eine große Demonstration, das ist mitten in der Großstadt, da erwartet man ja nicht, dass da hunderttausend Telefone sind. Das ist ja völlig überraschend. Ja und dann, völlig überraschend hat sich dann herausgestellt, dass da, ach da war ja auch noch die andere Abteilung, mit der haben wir ja gar nicht gesprochen und die hatte ja auch ein Imsycatcher zufällig im Rucksack. Also das ist halt der Stand der Information im Moment, was sie genau gemacht haben mit dem Imsycatcher, wofür sie ihn eingesetzt haben, wie oft, wie lange, wie viel Daten dabei angefallen sind und so weiter. Das ist halt alles noch nicht öffentlich bekannt, noch nicht irgendwie, sag ich mal, an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt.
Warten wir mal ab, vielleicht kommt da noch was bei rum. Ich hab jetzt sozusagen ganz gut entwickelt, was da alles rausgekommen ist. So ich würde jetzt gerne, bevor wir mit dem Imsycatcher weitermachen, weil ich würde dieses, mit dem kann man sich das selber basteln, gerne noch mal genauer klären. Wir haben jetzt einen Anrufer, der tatsächlich dem Aufruf vorhin gefolgt ist, um zu sagen, Vorratsdatenspeicherung ja oder nein. Und die Meinung beim Club ist ja relativ klar. Nee. Und er sagt, und das finde ich jetzt ganz spannend, ich würde es gerne kurz halten, aber ich würde es tatsächlich gerne mal kurz auch wirklich machen. Der sagt nämlich, der Jan, er hat keinen Mist gebaut, warum soll er dann dagegen sein und ist jetzt am Telefon. Tag Jan.
Hallo.
Du findest es also total super, wenn alle Leute sechs Monate lang ihre Verkehrsdaten gespeichert kriegen. Und zwar weil?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht so intensiv mit dem Thema beschäftigt, was Pro und Contra betrifft, aber ich habe nichts verbrochen. Und wenn auch nur der Hauch einer Chance besteht, damit irgendeinen Terroristen und sei es die Chance einer von 300.000 oder einer von drei Millionen oder irgendeinen, der in seinem normalen Job was total Ehrenwertes macht, aber nachts irgendwo Kinderpornografie runterlädt, den zu erwischen, dann finde ich das in Ordnung. Und derjenige, der das mit den Kindern meinetwegen macht, der wird vielleicht nicht fünfmal am Tag sein Handy wechseln.
Okay, das ist sozusagen so eine ganz klassische Extremargumentation, die anda bringt. Bitte.
Ja, was soll ich dazu sagen? Also in Bezug auf die Kinderpornografie, das ist ja in der Tat auch das Argument, was es war schon in EU-Papieren von 1996. Es war gesagt, das ist das wunderbarste Argument, um öffentliche Zustimmung zu bekommen, weil gegen Kinderpornografie sind alle. Das ist also natürlich konsensual. Man muss aber auch mal ein bisschen sehen, worum reden wir hier. Da müssen wir jetzt in die Materie einsteigen. So geht es um Missbrauch von Kindern oder geht es um Betrachten von Bildern. Verhindert man tatsächlich, dass Kinder missbraucht werden, wenn man diejenigen verfolgt, die sich solche Bilder angucken? Und ist das auch eine valide Rechtfertigung, um jetzt gleich mal alle Daten der gesamten Bevölkerung in Bezug auf ihr Telekommunikationsverhalten zu speichern? Weil darüber reden wir bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Wir möchten jetzt nicht eine Diskussion über Pornografie und Kinderpornografie und was auch immer halten.
Aber wenn das Argument kommt, kannst du es ja nicht komplett...
Mir geht es um jegliche Straftaten.
Jegliche?
Ja, also wer eine Straftat begeht, dafür gibt es ja Gesetze. Ich stimme natürlich zu.
Aber da hat ja Goethe, also Entschuldigung, da muss ich aber unterbrechen, weil dazu hat Goethe wirklich das Wichtige gesagt, wenn man alle Gesetze studieren würde, dann hätte man ja gar nicht mehr die Zeit, sie zu übertreten und dagegen zu verstoßen. Also wirklich jede Gesetze, wow.
Also ich möchte mal kurz sagen, Jan, also deine Argumentation zu Ende geführt, ist ja der Punkt, dass du sagst, wenn jemand kein Verbrechen begangen hat, hat er ja vor einer Vorratssattenspeicherung nichts zu befürchten. Du meinst sozusagen, dass es keine negativen Einflüsse auf einen normalen Menschen hat, wenn eine Vorratssattenspeicherung stattfindet. Da gibt es, glaube ich, eine andere Ansicht.
Ja, also ich möchte nur ganz kurz, bevor ich noch auf andere Punkte komme, dann mal sagen, gut, Filesharing ist ein Verstoß gegen Urhebergesetz, ist damit eine Straftat. Das heißt also jeder, der irgendwie mal ein Musikstück kopiert, unsrechtenmäßig, wäre dann also demnach schon irgendwie da drunter.
Hat doch noch nie jemand gemacht.
Ja, gut, ansonsten ist halt das Problem, dass diese Daten halt Bewegungsprofile auch enthalten und sehr viel Information über die einzelnen Personen. Die Frage ist dann eben, wer kann da drauf zugreifen? Ja, solche Datenbestände, wenn die erstmal irgendwo liegen, da gibt es große Interessen. Da gibt es vielleicht mal einen korrupten Polizeibeamten, der es dann natürlich auch wieder sich strafbar macht, aber der die Daten für was anderes benutzt. Es gibt vielleicht kriminelle Leute, die sich Zugang zu diesen Daten verschaffen. Und es sind halt schon sehr persönliche Dinge. Ja, da weiß man halt, ist jetzt jemand, keine Ahnung, wenn es jetzt um die Politik geht, ist jetzt jemand irgendwie, war der in dem Bordell oder nicht um die oder die Uhrzeit? Ja, und dann kann man da wieder einen öffentlichen Skandal draus machen und irgendwie, was weiß ich, da sozusagen die politische Karriere von Leuten beenden, nur weil man weiß, dass sie in einem bestimmten Ort waren, so in einer bestimmten Uhrzeit.
Also man kann mit den Daten, die man bemerkt, auch noch ganz andere Sachen machen. Wenn man jetzt mal über Wirtschaftsspionage oder Methoden redet, um irgendwie Straftaten zu begehen. Es sind ja hochinteressante Daten, wer wann wo ist. Es gab einen Fall in Köln vor Jahren, wo ein Mitarbeiter einer Bank, der dafür zuständig war, Überwachungsvideos auszuwerten, ein Muster bei einer bestimmten Filiale entdeckt hatte. Das funktionierte so, dass die Leute da mal mit dem Auto vorfahren konnten. Es war so eine Drive-In-Filiale quasi. Und es gab so ein Muster, wie die Kunden sich verhalten haben. Die sind also mit ihrem Auto vorgefahren, den Schlüsselbund noch in der Hand, haben den auf einen Kontostandsdrucker gelegt, ihre Karte reingeschickt, sich einen Kontostand ausdrucken lassen, dann weiter zum Geldautomaten, im PIN-Code eingeben, sich ein bisschen Kohle gezogen und sind damit da weitergefahren. Und was der gemacht hat, war, mit einem fein mechanisch begabten Freund zum einen aufgrund der Überwachungsvideos nach Schlüssel erzeugt haben, aufgrund der hochauflösenden Videos, die er von den Schlüsseln hatten, und zum anderen aufgrund der Daten, wann die Leute das nächste Mal in der Filiale waren, mit wiederum einem kleinen Netzwerk von Kumpels, den Leuten die Wohnung ausgeräumt hat. Und das ist vielleicht mal so ein kleines Beispiel, was klar macht, dass so Daten, die anfallen, in sogenannten Überwachungsvorgängen noch lange nicht dazu da sind Sicherheit zu erhöhen, sondern im Gegenteil hochgradig gefährlich sind, um Straftaten zu begehen, also um Unsicherheit quasi auszubauen. Und wir reden hier davon, wenn wir wirklich alle Vorratsdaten, also alle Daten der Telekommunikationsvorgänger, dann weißt du, wer mit wem Kontakt hat, du kannst Beziehungen, wirtschaftliche Verflechtung, alles Mögliche analysieren. Und das ist nicht nur für konkurrierende Unternehmen hochinteressant, sondern auch in menschlichen Zusammenhängen. Und ich will nicht in einer Gesellschaft leben, wo ich nicht mehr weiß, wer was über mich weiß. Und das genau ist ja die Begründung von Datenschutz überhaupt gewesen, informationelle Selbstbestimmung, dass man gesagt hat, wenn Leute nicht mehr wissen, was andere über sie wissen, dann werden sie sich nicht mehr so verhalten, wie sie sich verhalten und werden auch ihre demokratischen Rechte zu protestieren, sich zu organisieren und sofort nicht mehr wahrnehmen. Und darum geht es.
Jan, siehst du möglicherweise ein, dass es da auch eine Gegenargumentation gibt?
Logisch, keine Frage. Und dass die Kontrollmechanismen, dass das verstärkt werden muss, also wenn ich jetzt habe das jetzt von der Demonstration in Dresden das erste Mal gehört, aber dass da natürlich ein Parlamentarier geben muss, der dort Einblick bekommt und nicht hingehalten wird, also das versteht sich von selbst. Also gleich ist es ja mit dem Geheimdienst, Ausschuss und so weiter und so fort.
Okay, also ich empfehle dir einfach noch mal den Anfang der Sendung zu hören. Da haben wir schon mal ganz genau erklärt, wie sicher Behörden diese Daten verwalten hier anfangen. Und einen Tipp, Jan, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Einen Tipp würde ich da auch noch geben, in eine Diskussion, die schon jahrelang geführt wird einzusteigen mit. Ich habe mich jetzt nicht so ausführlich damit beschäftigt, aber ich habe eine sehr extreme Meinung. Könnte man noch mal drüber nachdenken? So, hätten wir das also auch geklärt mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung? Gut, ihr könnt weiterhin noch anrufen. Wie gesagt, also die Diskussion läuft schon eine Weile und wenn man eine extreme Meinung hat, dann sollte man die schon auch gut begründen können. Finde ich zumindest machbar. Zurück zum Imseacatcher. Wir hatten festgestellt, was man mit alles machen kann und ihr hattet ganz am Anfang gesagt, man kann sich ja auch selber bauen. Jetzt ist es ja bei dem selber Bauen immer so ein Sache. Also theoretisch könnte man sich auch einen Space Shuttle selber bauen. Das macht nur keiner, weil es so super komplex ist. Wie einfach ist es denn wirklich so ein Ding zu machen?
Ja, das ist heutzutage total leicht. Ich bin selber ja sehr aktiv im Bereich Open-Source-Entwicklung zu GSM-Protokollen. Und hab tatsächlich also mir im Laufe der letzten Jahre eben Software dafür geschrieben. Jetzt nicht speziell für den IMSEE-Catcher. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich Software habe, die ein Mobilfunknetz implementiert, kann ich natürlich ein echtes Netz implementieren. Ich kann aber auch ein falsches Netz implementieren. Wenn ich ein falsches Netz habe, habe ich die falsche Basisstation. Da gibt es eine Reihe von, also drei von Projekten in letzter Zeit, die das ein bisschen öffentlicher machen. Zunächst bleibt mir historisch, ich glaube so 1994 herum ist die erste öffentlich bekannte Dokumentation von dem Imseacatcher und zwar eine Patentschrift der deutschen Firma Rode & Schwarz, die sogenannte Virtual Base Station, die virtuelle Basisstation. Da geht es also eben genau um diese Man in the Middle Angriff, den wir schon beschrieben haben, den sie da machen. Das heißt also, sei mal technisch bekannt, wie das funktioniert, öffentlich ist spätestens seit 1994, seitdem es dieses Patent gibt. Dann gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Firmen, diese ganze Sicherheitsindustrie, von der Andy von vorhin schon gesprochen hatte, die kommerzielle Geräte verkaufen in dem Bereich. Manche davon verkaufen das halt nur an Behörden, sag ich mal. Ja, weil die Frage ist, was sind das für Behörden? Und wenn es jetzt, was es sich der Pakistanische Geheimdienst hat, ist es dann auch eine legitime Behörde, die sowas gekauft hat. Die können das dann nach Deutschland mitbringen, können da irgendwelche Forschungen, also irgendwelche Spionage damit anstellen. So ist immer die Frage. Ja, nur Behörden heißt halt auch, naja, Behörden jedes Landes.
Die pakistanische Regierung ist ja zugleich ein schlechtes Beispiel. Die sind doch bei jedem Zweifel erhaben.
Ach so, ja, das wissen wir. Ja, deswegen habe ich ja dieses Beispiel gewähnt. Ja, können auch die amerikanischen Freunde ansprechen. Aber jedenfalls will ich mal gesagt haben, gut, es gibt eine Industrie, es gibt eine Branche, wo man die kaufen kann. Da gibt es seriösere Anbieter, da gibt es weniger seriöse Anbieter. Das heißt, wenn ich ein bisschen Geld auf der Tasche habe, dann kann ich mir so ein Ding auch einfach kaufen. Dann brauche ich nicht selber bauen. Hausnummer? Heutzutage, denke ich, ist man inzwischen im fünfstelligen Bereich angekommen. Vor ein paar Jahren musste man da schon noch so 100.000, 200.000 Euro irgendwie auspacken.
Aber wenn du jetzt über Nanozellen, Picozellen solltest du vielleicht auch noch reden. Das sind ja eigentlich auch BTS, also wie man sagt, Base Station Prinziper, die dasselbe machen und die nur entsprechend programmiert werden müssen.
Entschuldigung, Nanozellen bitte was?
Gleich. Diese Geldbeträge, die ich hier gesehen habe, das ist jetzt sozusagen die klassische Überwachungstechnologie-Anbieterindustrie, wo ich einfach hingehen kann, ich kaufe die irgendwie rundum glücklich Variante, ich kann nur Maus schubsen, ich weiß überhaupt nichts von der Technik, dann kann ich mir da was kaufen und das ist mit Schulung und allem drum und dran und dann funktioniert das. Ja, die Selberbau-Variante ist natürlich deutlich...
Auf die Behörde geeignet.
Richtig, auch ich, genau. Ja, jedenfalls wenn ich das selber bauen will, kann ich das deutlich leichter haben. Also ich kann mir Hardware kaufen, die inzwischen, sag ich mal, sich im Bereich von 1000 Dollar oder so bewegt, also was, was ich wirklich jedermann noch irgendwie leisten kann. Ja, das ist irgendwie zwei Smartphones, so ungefähr, vom Preis her. Also Hardware für den Betrag, dann benutze ich irgendwie Open-Source-Software, die für jedermann zur Verfügung steht, die muss ich noch ein bisschen richtig konfigurieren und muss noch hier und da ein bisschen was drehen, aber dann habe ich das Ganze.
Die gibt es aber auch schon.
Die gibt es schon, ja, das ist eben keine Imseacatcher-Software an sich, sondern es ist Software, die dir erlaubt, ein GSM-Netz zu betreiben. Da gibt es einmal das sogenannte Open-BTS-Projekt und auf der anderen Seite das Open-BSC-Projekt. Das sind beides Projekte, mit denen man sein GSM-Netz-Server betreiben kann. Und ein Imseacatcher, wie wir gerade erfahren haben, ist ja eigentlich nichts anderes als ein GSM-Netz, was nur sich falsch ausweist.
Also das hört sich jetzt an, wenn ich einen 1000 auf der Kante habe, dann hole ich mir so einen Teil, spiele ich Software drauf und dann geht es los. Jetzt ist es ja gerade bei Open-Source-Software so, dass es nicht immer so ganz einfach ist. Wie hoch muss denn der, also mein Fähigkeitswert sagen, also muss ich mich dann schon wirklich da reinknien? Oder ist es wirklich so irgendwie, ich klick mir so ein Ding im Shop und dann lese ich mir irgendwie drei How-To's im Internet durch und dann läuft es?
Naja, das kommt im Wesentlichen darauf an, so was für Know-How bringt man mit. Wenn ich jetzt mal sage, so ich bin irgendwie in der Fit, ich entwickele selber irgendwie Software, ich kenne Computersysteme, ich kenne mich ein bisschen mit Kommunikationssystemen aus, so in die Richtung, dann ist es natürlich nicht so super schwer. Dann würde ich sagen, bis es mal sauber funktioniert und getestet ist in ein paar Wochen oder so, jemand, der jetzt weniger Erkenntnisse mitbringt, der wird sicherlich einfach nur damit er weiß, muss erstmal verstehen, wie funktioniert dieses GSM Netz, was genau macht jetzt irgendwie so ein IMSI-Catcher, wie konfiguriere ich diese Software und so weiter, da würde ich dann schon sagen, es ist vielleicht im Monatsbereich, also ich sage mal im einstelligen Monatsbereich, was er da irgendwie an Aufwand hineinstecken muss.
Also ein Teil der Komplexität besteht sicherlich darin, dass man sich mal kurz einlesen muss, wie GSM tatsächlich funktioniert, also wie eben die Trennung der Frequenzbereiche, Organisationskanäle und so fort stattfindet, auch wie die Handoverprozeduren, also wie Telefone ihre Zellen wechseln und so fort, da muss man sich schon ein bisschen reinlesen. Und damit wollte ich auch ganz kurz noch einen Seitenschwenk eröffnen, nämlich abgesehen von der Variante, sich so eine kleine Zelle zu holen und sich die mit Open Software zu programmieren, gibt es auch noch die Variante des rein Passivens, erst mal zuhören, da gibt es Geräte, also kann man sich vorstellen wie ein Scanner, also wie ein Empfänger, der Vollprogrammierer ist, es gibt den sogenannten GNU Radio Entwicklungsstrang, das sind Geräte, die kosten zwischendurch auch so etwas 1500, 1200, ja, geht bei 1000 an inzwischen, gibt es auch billigere, bei 3000 Dollar, ja, und nächste Woche ist da ein Dollar dann ja eh, der US-Slot, die wird dann ja günstiger, und dann gibt es da auch schon teilweise Softwarekomponenten, Mit dem man zumindest da schon mal reinhorchen kann. Reinhorchen heißt jetzt nicht, sorry, klingt jetzt so, als wenn man dazuhören kann, kann man auch nicht, aber man kann sich dann schon mal das Protokoll angucken. Das heißt, man kann sich schon mal angucken, was in seiner Funktion so los ist.
Also als Vergleich sagen sie es, wie ein verschlüsseltes WLAN mitzuschneiden. Das heißt, du hast schon mal einfach alle Daten auf der Platte und dann kann man später mal gucken, was man damit macht.
Ja, es ist ja nicht alles verschlüsselt.
Ja, also es ist durchaus machbar. Das wurde ja auch inzwischen mehrfach demonstriert. Wir hatten am diversen ZTC-Kongressen dazwischen Vorträge und Demonstrationen, auch auf anderen Konferenzen in den USA im IT-Security-Bereich, ist das hinlänglich oft demonstriert worden, dass man sich nun echt mit extrem wenig Geld und wenig Aufwand irgendwie einen Imseacatcher selber bauen kann. Und das, was da passiert, ist ja nur, wie soll ich sagen, eine Demokratisierung dieser Technik und auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite eben einfach ein Mehrbewusstmachen, dass das geht. Das ist nicht so, dass jetzt erst seit ein, zwei Jahren diese Technik verfügbar ist. Die Technik ist seit, wie gesagt, mindestens 1994 verfügbar. Es ist nur so, dass jetzt jeder sich selber ein Bild davon machen kann und sich davon überzeugen kann, wie funktioniert das. Und auch schon vor, was weiß ich, schon vor zehn Jahren habe ich Gerüchte gehört, dass die britische Presse, also die Tabloids irgendwie in England durchaus Imseacatcher auf Prominente ansetzen. Also dass die schon damals Imseacatcher hatten, weil sie halt einfach vielleicht die nächste große Story über das Königshaus und die Affären ist halt einfach so viel mehr wert als diese 100.000 Euro, die man für den Imseacatcher ausgeben muss. Da kann man mal leicht so ein Gerät kaufen, um irgendwie die Königsfamilie abzuhören.
Das ist ja auch bei News of the World nebenbei, wer merkt durchaus noch, im Moment geht es ja um das Abhören der Voice-Mailboxen. Das war ein vergleichsweise technisch primitiver Angriff, aber auch da ist noch nicht ganz raus, ob da nicht auch GSM-Abhörmaschinen benutzt wurden. Also bei den Mörderunternehmen.
Ich halte mal fest, Imsy-Catcher selber machen, fällt in die Kategorie aufwändigeres, komplexeres Hobby, aber ist auf jeden Fall machbar, wenn man will.
Also vielleicht noch dazu...
Ja, so laubsige Arbeiten und GSM-Abhören, das...
Vielleicht noch dazu, also inzwischen ist es auch so, dass es einige Bachelor- und Masterarbeiten in dem Bereich gibt.
Man findet im Netz schon auch...
Nicht, dass in den Arbeiten wirklich was Neues sind, stünde, aber da kann man auch das Niveau sehen. Ein Informatikstudent, der eine Abschlussarbeit schreibt, wenn man dieses Niveau hat technisch, dann schafft man es in jedem Fall.
Okay, alles klar, wisst ihr Bescheid, wo ihr verstehen müsst, wenn ihr euch einen eigenen IMSEE-Catcher bauen wollt. So, dann haben wir jetzt also die Funkzellenauswertung, dann haben wir den IMSEE-Catcher. Aber der IMSEE-Catcher macht ja schon so ein bisschen, wie heißt das, ich vergesse es immer wieder, semi-passiv?
Der IMSEE-Catcher ist irgendwie so ein einfacher Begriff, aber das ist tatsächlich das Primitivste der Geräte. Man redet ansonsten von passiven oder semi-passiven.
Oder auch semi-aktiven.
Oder semi-aktiven Dingern. Die machen dann eben, also die reinen Passiven, das ist auf der einen Seite, dass es einen programmierbaren Empfänger hat, der die Signale entsprechend rausholt und sortiert. Man muss ja sehen, dass so ein Mobiltelefon, wenn man eins abhören will, unter Umständen mehrfach während eines Gesprächs, wenn es sich bewegt, die Funkzelle und damit auch die Frequenz wechselt. Und die muss man quasi hinterher schalten, damit man das Gespräch voll abhören kann. Und dann braucht man noch Gerätschaften, um das Ganze zu dekodieren, also zu entschlüsseln. Es gibt ja drei verschiedene Algorithmen, die im GSM eingesetzt werden, um die Sprache zu verschlüsseln. Und dann gibt es noch A5, also die fangen alle mit A5 an. A50 ist eigentlich kein Algorithmus, es ist nämlich keine Verschlüsselung. Muss man trotzdem erwähnen, gibt es immer noch Länder und Mobiltelefone, die das komischerweise unterstützen, auch wenn anderes behauptet wird. Dann gibt es der Dominant im Einsatz, würde ich sagen, der Dominant ist A52, oder?
Nein, A51 ist der gängige Algorithmus. Also es gibt mehrere Algorithmen, aber da kommen wir jetzt eben auch in die Inhalte hinein.
Genau, darauf wollte ich hinaus. Da sind wir ja auch. Fast schon Ende der Sendung, also halbe Stunde haben wir noch, aber jetzt gibt es das Leckerli, das Dessert. Inhaltliche Überwachung, also ich möchte nicht nur wissen, wer da wo wann mit wem telefoniert wird, sondern ich möchte verdammt nochmal auch wissen, was hat der gesagt?
Also der A5.1-Algorithmus ist technisch schon durch, kann man sagen.
Technisch schon durch heißt sozusagen, existiert noch, aber es kann jeder Bastler ihn knacken.
Richtig, ja.
Warte mal, ich hab halt noch kurz einen Schritt zurück. Entschuldigung, kurz einen Schritt zurück. Also ich muss ja sozusagen, bevor ich diese Daten entschlüssel, muss ich an die ran kommen. Da gibt's ja sozusagen, hab ich drei Wege. Ich kann einerseits über diesen MC-Catcher gehen, also beziehungsweise dieses wie auch immer geartete Gerät, was Geräte, was diese Daten mitschneiden kann.
Ja, sagen wir einen Interceptor.
Ein Interceptor. Okay, kein MC-Catcher, ein Interceptor. Ist der dann genauso leicht zu bauen? Ja klar, ich muss einfach nur die Base Station machen.
Noch leichter eigentlich. Passiv oder semi-passiv?
Passiv.
Okay, rein passiv ist es tatsächlich, kannst du genug Radio nehmen und musst ihn nur programmieren.
Okay, dann hab ich so eine Art, der schneidet einfach mit, was du gerade an den Sender befroren hast.
Also ein Gerät für 1000 US-Dollar und ein bisschen Software.
Vielleicht nochmal für die Leute, die da mehr dazu lesen wollen, die frei erhältliche Open Source Software, die man dafür nehmen kann für dieses rein Mithören, nennt sich Air Probe, also wie Air, also die Luft und Probe, ja die Sonde, genau. Die Hardware, um die es da geht, die wir ansprechen, ist zum Beispiel das USRP, das ist das Universal Software Radio Peripheral. Das ist ein Gerät, was man an USB anschließt und was eine Antenne hat. Und das Gerät zusammen mit dieser Radio Software und dieser Air Probe Software kann man dann eben benutzen dafür.
Also ich nehme Hardware und schneide den GSM-Funk quasi mit, das ist die eine Variante, dann kann ich natürlich zumindest auf Schadlichstelle auch immer wieder zum Anbieter gehen und sagen Alter, gib mal einen Halter.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist nicht...
Es geht erstmal nur darum, wie ich an den Halter rankomme. Das geht doch, oder?
Zum Netzbetreiber kannst du aber nur gehen, wenn du im Nachrichtendienst bist, in der Polizei, und nicht wenn du ein Hacker bist und deine Nachbar nachbehalten willst.
Wir haben ja die Sendung angefangen mit den Hacker. Ich würde schon gerne auch, dass wir wenigstens kurz dabei bleiben. Die müssen es aber vorher Bescheid sagen.
Also in den Netzen gibt es ja neben der Möglichkeit, die Verkehrsdaten und die erhobenen Daten in irgendeiner Form abzufragen, auch noch die sogenannten Lovel Interception, das heißt die Abhörmöglichkeiten, die vorgesehen sind, die setzen allerdings tatsächlich voraus, dass da gesagt wird, ok, dieser Teilnehmer wird abgehört, und dann wird immerhin in Echtzeit, also live quasi, werden die übertragenen Gespräche auch nochmal über eine Stelle, geschlossene Benutzungsgruppe im ISDN Netz, den Behörden dann übermittelt, um sie dort aufzuzeichnen.
Frage ist das sozusagen, die Polizei geht hin und sagt, wir möchten ab jetzt abhören? Das ist nicht wie dieses vollautomatische, ich frag mal eben abwärts in den Anschluss gehört, das muss schon sagen.
Also das ist auch wieder dieses richterliche Verfahren mit dem Vorbehalt, den wir vorhin ja...
Aber nicht bei den Nachrichtendiensten, da ist es kein richterliches Verfahren.
Das ist richtig, ja. Also gut, es gibt gesetzliche Anforderungen, warum, wer da hinkommen kann. Das sind die sogenannten berechtigten Stellen. Das ist auch ein bisschen das Vokabular hier mit reinzubringen. Also wir sprechen jetzt über die sogenannte Telekommunikations... Bedarfsträger ist auch Behörndeutsch. Im Gesetz steht die berechtigte Stelle. Wird auch in den ganzen technischen Richtlingen immer als BS bezeichnet, die berechtigte Stelle. Ja, die berechtigte Stelle kann also eben einer dieser Geheimdienste, die Polizei sein. Und was sehr interessant ist, was sie also alles geregelt haben zum Beispiel, ist, dass mehrere berechtigte Stellen gleichzeitig, und zwar bis zu drei gleichzeitig, können den gleichen abhören. Und die dürfen voneinander nicht wissen, dass sie alle den gleichen abhören.
Und Harald, du bist nicht auf dem letzten Stand. Das wurde erweitert. Das müssen jetzt fünf gleichzeitig abhören können ohne.
Ja, da hab ich wieder was verpasst. Es ist schon ein paar Jahre her, dass ich mir das alles durchgelesen hatte. Wir hatten da auch schon mal ein Chaosradio dazu gemacht, als es neu kam mit der TKÜV. Das sind also mehrere Stellen, die unanfänglich voneinander das gleiche Telefon abhören können und voneinander gegenseitig nicht wissen dürfen, dass die anderen abhören. So genau ist das alles geregelt. Da werden dann die Inhalte ausgeleitet. Das betrifft nicht nur die Gespräche, es betrifft genauso SMS oder E-Mails oder was auch immer man eben so tut, mit dem Telefon oder mit seinem Computer.
Das ist natürlich das Unaufwendigste, zumindest wenn das dann geklappt hat. Der dritte Fall, den ich mir aufgeschrieben habe, so stelle ich mir das zumindest vor, viele Leute haben ja Smartphones, also eher kleine Rechner als die alten Mobiltelefone. Da stelle ich mir vor, da könnte man einfach eine Software drauf spielen und dann damit mithören.
Da sind wir beim Thema Bundeszirianer oder die sogenannte Quellen-TKÜ. TKÜ für Telekommunikationsüberwachung, Quelle, weil das Telefon ist die Quelle der Kommunikation. Das hat man sich ausgedacht, weil die bösen Kriminellen und auch nicht Kriminellen, die haben sich ja erlaubt und erdreistet, Verschlüsselung einzusetzen. Also sowas wie um Gottes willen. Sie fangen an, ihre Kommunikation zu verschlüsseln. Und was müssen wir da machen? Wir müssen also Schadsoftware auf dem Endgerät installieren, um bevor der Verschlüsselungsvorgang aktiv wird in dem Gerät, die Daten noch abzugreifen.
Das ist also nachdem sie entschlüsselt wurden. Und das ist auch angefangen hat, dieses Problem erst in der Fläche tatsächlich ein Problem zu werden, durch Skype. Skype verschlüsselt zwar die Gespräche nicht so, dass Skype darauf kein Zugefetter, aber Skype ist eben keine in Deutschland beistutweise greifbares Unternehmen, das man mal so kurz dem Telekommunikationsgesetz unterstellen kann, weil die ja damit nicht mal Geld verdienen, sondern einfach nur Software im Netz verteilen.
Und Geld verdienen ist ja kein Punkt.
Na gut, geschäftsmäßig ist richtig. Aber der Punkt ist dann der, also die Quellen-TKÜ ist eigentlich schon Propagandabehördendeutsch. Im Gesetz heißt das ja nicht so, sondern das ist ja die Behauptung, dass man eben eine Telekommunikationsüberwachung an der Quelle machen würde. Da sind wir auch gleich wieder beim Bundesrujaner. Das ist nämlich dasselbe. Die technischen Dienstleister, wenn man jetzt im Netz danach googelt, dann sollte man nach Rimut Forensik Tools suchen. Und das ist auch eine Propagandalüge, weil Forensik heißt ja quasi Daten beweis-sicher zu erheben. Und das Problem bei so einem Projaner ist, dass man eben nicht mehr beweis-sicher sagen kann, welche Daten eigentlich durch den Verdächtigen in diesem Fall erstellt oder verarbeitet wurden und welche Daten durch den Trojaner da reingebracht wurden.
Ich glaube, diese Sache mit dem Bundestrojaner und Remote Forensik Software, das ist doch mal ein anderer Schnacke, wie man dann an manchen auch noch sagt. Wir haben jetzt erst mal festgestellt, also wenn ich an die Inhalte eines Mobiltelefons ran will, kann ich es auf drei verschiedenen Wegen machen. Welche davon der einfachste ist und welchen wir vielleicht mal selber ausprobieren werden könnten, zum selber basteln. Kleiner Vergleich. Vorher gibt es das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Genau genommen Chaosradio mit Markus Richter und natürlich den Leuten aus dem Chaos Computer Club, Andy Müller-Maguhn und Harald Welte, die euch heute darüber aufklären, wie man so ein Mobiltelefon mal ganz aufwendig und auch unaufwendig überwachen und orten kann. Wir haben schon geklärt im Verlaufe dieser Sendung, was eine funkzellen-Auswertung ist, was Verkehrsdaten sind, was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung bringt, wie man sich selber einen IMSI-Catcher baut. Und jetzt sind wir quasi gerade bei der Creme, nämlich der inhaltlichen Überwachen, also jemanden tatsächlich und wirklich abhören. Wir haben vor der Nachricht schon kurz geklärt, man kann das machen, indem man auch das Telefon selber eine Software spielt, die das vielleicht schon zerledigt. Direkt beim Anbieter und indem man einfach den GSM-Funk abhört. Ich fasse das nochmal zusammen, Harald, was du gerade erzählt hast. Die Software dafür kann man sich aus dem Netz laden und dann selber irgendwie an den Start bringen. Die Hardware dazu kostet 1000 Dollar ungefähr.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also das ist die reine Empfänger-Hardware. Wenn ich noch entschlüsseln will, also die Schlüssel brechen will und die Verschlüsselung, die da eingesetzt wird, dann muss ich noch ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgeben, aber das ist auch nur so ein PC mit zweitigen Grafikkarten.
Okay, da hab ich ja sowieso zu Hause stehen, weil ich gerade Bitcoins generiere. Okay, ich hab jetzt also dieses Ding, also dieses Empfangsgerät, das dropt mir quasi den gesamten GSM-Funk einfach auf meine Platte. Was mach ich dann damit?
Ja, das ist die gute Frage. Was möchtest du tun?
Im Prinzip möchtest du sagen, keine Ahnung, der Fall ist natürlich, dass ich total eifersüchtig bin und die Telefonate meiner Freundin abhören möchte, ohne dass sie es merkt.
Ja, naja gut, vielleicht nochmal aber auch im Allgemeinen, was es da für Herangehensweisen gibt. Ich denke, da gibt es zwei grundsätzlich unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen. Das eine ist eher so die geheimdienstliche Methode. Da will man halt mal alles erfassen, was geht. Und so ein bisschen durch Rasterfahndung, also das Analysieren von Unmengen von Daten, irgendwelche Verhaltensauffälligkeiten herausfinden, soziale Netzwerke von Dissidenten in irgendwelchen Staaten, die halt nicht so freundlich gegenüber irgendwelchen Bürgeraktivitäten gesinnt sind. Solche Dinge, die geheimdienstliche Herangehensweise und dann gibt es eher so die klassisch polizeiliche Herangehensweise. Bei der polizeilichen Herangehensweise, da hat man eben, sei mal im Idealfall eine Ermittlung gegen eine Person oder gegen einen kleinen Personenkreis, und dann will man gezielt diese Personen abhören. Da ist also nicht die Vollerfassung in der Breite, sondern eben wirklich in die Tiefe auf bestimmte Personen. Dazwischen gibt es natürlich alle möglichen Stufen. Und je nachdem, was ich jetzt erfassen will, eignen sich bestimmte Methoden besser oder weniger gut. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, die Polizei in Deutschland möchte, was weiß ich, dies oder jenes ermitteln, dann ist für die Polizei in der Regel das Leichteste, zum Netzpilseiber zu gehen und das irgendwo auf Netzseite zu tun. Da muss man nicht mit Fahrzeugen rumfahren und muss kein spezielles Equipment irgendwo hinstellen und so weiter. Das ist alles teuer, es kostet Geld. Und ja, es ist viel billiger, das auf der Netzseite zu machen. Wenn ich jetzt natürlich als ausländischer Geheimdienst in Deutschland unterwegs bin und irgendwelche deutschen Politiker oder Wirtschaftsgrößen überwachen will, oder die Polizei, oder die deutsche Polizei, oder den deutschen Geheimdienst überwachen will, dann kann ich natürlich nicht zu dem deutschen Netzbetreiber gehen, sagen, hallo, ich hätte hier gerne mal irgendwie überwacht.
Deswegen gründen ja ausländische Geheimdienste Telekommunikationsbetreiber, die dann in Deutschland Netzbetreiber sind, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Oh, wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Das ist nochmal ein richtig anderes Thema. Oder bin ich jetzt ein organisierter Krimineller?
Also worauf ich eigentlich hinaus soll, ist der technische Ansatz. Weil wir haben ja vorhin schon mal, habt ihr kurz erzählt, irgendwie GSM hat verschiedene Verschlüsselungsstufen. Da gibt es eine, die ist sozusagen eigentlich egal, weil es da quasi Klartext ist. Ihr habt auch gesagt, es gibt verschiedene Sachen, die übertragen werden. Die sind gar nicht verschlüsselt, sondern die kann man einfach so mithören. Ich wollte eigentlich nochmal darauf hinaus sagen, was man da machen muss und wie schwierig das ist.
Wenn man jetzt ganz kurz mal den behördlichen Bereich gesiebt, also die Module, die angeboten werden für Behörden, die Telekommunikationen mit passiven oder semi-passiven Geräten abhören wollen, da zahlt man für so eine Kiste, die A52 macht, zahlt man irgendwas so 100.000.
Aber wir sprechen immer noch von viel Geld für uns.
Ja, gut, das ist ja alles... Also wir reden hier ja von Investition zum Ende. Das ist jetzt aus Sicht einer kriminellen Organisation betrachtet und es geht darum, dass du aus den Erkenntnissen jemanden erpressen willst oder so weiter und so fort, dann redest du okay. Hunderttausend ist ja viel Geld, aber wenn du damit Millionen verdienen kannst, dann ist das ganz wenig Geld. Also man muss das ja mal in Relation sehen mit dem Nutzen, den man damit erzielen kann, auch ökonomisch. Und die teuersten Geschichten oder die aufwendigsten, also A51 kann man sagen zunächst einmal, ist noch im Bereich von, also zumindest den Katalog, den ich in der Hand hatte, da kostete das noch eine Viertel Million. Und A53, das ist also der Angebot, der jetzt auch beim GSM, beim UMTS, also beim 3G eingesetzt wird. Da kenne ich kein Gerät, was man direkt mobil unterwegs betreiben kann. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da schon was gesehen hast, aber...
Nicht direkt, was man da halt macht, also...
Ist da das Dropping auf 2G runter, das man durch gezielte Störungen des Kanals so tut, als gibt es im 3G-Gard irgendein Problem und das Gerät dazu bringt, doch wieder 2G zu machen. Aber das lassen nicht alle Telefone mit sich machen. Ich weiß, dass es im Behördenbereich die Anordnung gibt, bestimmte Geräte nur einzusetzen, die eben genau dieses Feature haben, nämlich sich nicht aus dem 3G rauswerfen zu lassen. Das ist schon ein Sicherheitsfeature.
Ja gut, mal dahingestellt, ja. Aber es gibt diese unterschiedlichen Verschlüsselungsverfahren, die zu knacken. Das gängigste, was man eben heute noch bei den Mobilfunkanbietern findet, also 99% aller Mobiltelefonate in Deutschland zumindest werden über A51 verschlüsselt. Das Verfahren ist seit vielen Jahren in der, sag ich mal, Kryptographenszene gebrochen. Seit, ich weiß nicht mehr, war 1997 die erste Veröffentlichung oder so dazu auf einer kryptographischen Konferenz. Man muss sich auch immer vor Augen halten, das System, über das wir hier reden, GSM, ist eine Entwicklung Mitte der 80er Jahre. Wurde zum ersten Mal eingesetzt 1990, waren die ersten Netze da. Und wir sind jetzt im Jahr 2011. Das heißt, wir sprechen über was, was vor 20, 25 Jahren entwickelt wurde. Da ist natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen klar, dass es einfach heute nicht mehr so den Anforderungen gewachsen ist. Und dass die Computer alle schneller wurden und man Fortschritte gemacht hat im Bereich der Mathematik und so weiter.
Okay, das heißt, was mich hier langsam fragt, wir haben heute schon viel gelernt, weil die meisten Leute benutzen ein Handy quasi als dieses Gerät. Das ist das magische Anmachtding, und dann telefoniere ich damit und das ist schon alles super. Und was man heute auf jeden Fall in den zwei Stunden lernt, ist, das ist also auf relativ vielen Wegen angreifbar. Also viel mehr als ich viele Leute wahrscheinlich vorgestellt habe. Was mich gerade frage ist, wie benutzt ihr denn selber Handys? Also benutzt ihr die überhaupt noch? Oder ist das dann eher so, dass ihr so sagt, ha ha, ne lieber nicht? Oder ist das dann wie bei E-Mail? Da sagen ja die meisten sozusagen datenschutzbewussten Menschen, okay E-Mail muss man wie Postkarte betrachten, da schreibt man eigentlich nichts rein, was man nicht öffentlich sagen würde.
Ich habe vor Jahren mal etwas gelesen, über wie bei der Staatssicherheit Datenverarbeitung funktioniert hat. Und da hat, ich glaube der Büroleiter von Mielke oder sowas, hatte in seinen Memoaren so einen lustigen Abparagrafen, wo er eben gesagt hat, naja, es gab dann bei uns die Aktenvernichter, wenn wir also Akten vernichten wollen, dann gab es die Mülleimer. Und die Mülleimer, da haben wir die Dokumente reingelegt, das war quasi unser Übermittlungsweg an die ausländischen Nachrichtendienste, wenn wir denen etwas mitteilen oder wenn wir denen Desinformationen beimitteln wollten. Und so kann ich persönlich sagen, benutze ich Telekommunikationsfragen zwangsläufig. Natürlich gibt es immer noch Leute, mit denen ich unverschlüsselt telefonieren muss, aber es gibt eben auch Verschlüsselungstelefone, wo ich zufällig was mit zu tun habe. Aber davon unabhängig, also natürlich kommt man nicht drumrum, unverschlüsselt, wir sagen auf dem normalen Telefonnetz zu telefonieren, aber trotzdem will man da eben nicht alle Gespräche führen, ganz sicher nicht. Und das ist das Problem an der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das Ganze führt zwangsläufig zu einer Verhaltensänderung.
Ja, und da muss man auch wieder unterscheiden, die Verschlüsselung selber bringt dir bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ja auch nichts. Die Inhalte kann ich noch so sehr schützen, diese Verkehrsdaten, die fallen trotzdem an.
Na ja, es kommt drauf an.
Na ja, man kann da schon auch noch Dinge verschleiern und so weiter.
Das ist ja durchaus eine spannende Frage, weil nach dem, was wir heute hier gehört haben, ist es so, sobald mein Handy an ist, bin ich ja sozusagen da drin.
Das ist richtig. Wenn du auf die Art und Weise deine Gespräche aufbaust, dass du einen Datenkanal zwischen dir und deinem Kommunikationspartner aufbaust und darüber direkt verschlüsselst, das von deinem Mobiltelefon machst, dann sieht man das unter Umständen im Netz. Aber wenn man erst noch über ein Servernetzwerk geht, wo eben das Ganze eher aussieht wie eine VPN-Verbindung, dann kann man da schon was machen. Und zumindest für Messaging gibt es schon funktionierende Sachen, wo das eben über Tor geht, also über so ein Anonymisierungsnetzwerk. Und ich würde mal kognostizieren, so in ein paar Jahren wird es das auch für Sprache geben. Das hängt im Moment noch an der Latenz, also an der Verzögerung, die da entsteht, wenn man eine Anonymisierung der Datenverbindung quasi betreibt. Das ist im Moment funktioniert, das für Sprache einfach gar nicht.
Ja, also das ist sicherlich möglich. Man kann da Dinge tun, aber es sind immer sowas wie, wo ist dieses Telefon gerade, das ist einfach eine Information, die zwangsweise dem Mobiltelefonnetz bekannt sein muss. Die müssen ja wissen, über welchen Sende-Masten können sie gerade mit deinem Telefon reden. Also wissen sie, wo dein Telefon ist.
Klar, wenn du in ein Mobilnetz eingebucht bist.
Also das gibt eben bestimmte Grenzen, da kommt man nicht drum rum.
Du kannst ja über IP telefonieren, da benutzt du einfach das nächste WLAN. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass es keine Alternativen gibt, um mobile Telekommunikation zu machen.
Naja, also eine wirkliche Alternative würde ich es nicht ansehen. Also du kannst das Telefon ausschalten, du kannst irgendwie einen öffentlichen Münz Fernsprecher benutzen.
Ich kann hier verschlüsselt über WLAN telefonieren, brauche ich kein GSM, brauche ich nicht im GSM-Netz.
Ja, dann bist du nicht im GSM-Netz, aber du bist irgendwie hier im IP-Netz, was genauso Vorratsdaten irgendwie anlegt. Fast.
Wieso? Wo liegt das Vorratsdaten dann?
Naja, weil es einen Internetprovider gibt, der hier dem Rundfunk Berlin Brandenburg irgendwie einen Internetanschluss legt und der ist auch wieder unterliegt der Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung.
Aber nicht im selben Umfang wie ein Telekommunikationsanbieter. Also, okay, da gibt es schon Unterschiede in Bezug auf wer Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen in welcher Form anbringt. Ich sehe da schon auch eine Chance drin, dass das IP sozusagen andere Möglichkeiten bietet, weil wir sind ja auch gerade jetzt mal unabhängig von dem Überwachungsthema. Das gesamte Telefonnetz wird ja gerade quasi umgestellt und die zu Grunde liegen über Traumstechnik, die bislang esoterische Angelegenheiten wie ATM waren und irgendwelche X-Protokolle. Das wird ja alles auf IP gerade geschmissen. Und auf der einen Seite ist das ein riesen Problem, weil die Verfügbarkeit, also unter dem Aspekt der Betriebssicherheit, ist das eigentlich ein riesen Problem, weil die ganzen Internetprobleme jetzt auch ins Telefonnetz reinkommen. Aber auf der anderen Seite kommen auch die ganzen Chancen, die Daten ganz anders zu handhaben und ganz anders zu verteilen und auch zwischendurch zu verschlüsseln. Solche Sachen, die bislang sehr mühselig waren mit anderen Protokollen, die geraten jetzt auch im Bereich der Möglichkeiten für die Telekommunikation. Das ist auch eine Chance.
Ist der Ausblick zu sagen eher optimistisch, weil Harald, du meinst jetzt die ganze Zeit, wir telefonieren mit einer Technik aus den 80er Jahren. Würdest du sagen, in der nächsten Zeit was tun, wo man sagen kann, mobile Datenübertragung, das müsste man wahrscheinlich dann schon sagen, wird zeitgemäß?
Ich habe eine beschränkte Hoffnung. Spätestens bei LTE. Wenn man das GSM hat, danach kommt 3G, dann kann man noch sagen 35G, also HSPA-beschleunigte Verfahren. Dann kommt 4G, also das LTE-System, wo jetzt die ersten Basis-Stationen irgendwo in Brandenburg und irgendwie in was weiß ich wo stehen. Da gibt es keine klassische leitungsgebundene Telefonie mehr in diesem System. Das ist alles nur noch Internet, das ist alles nur noch IP. Telefonie gibt es an sich nicht mehr, da macht man halt dann Voice-over-IP. Ab dem Zeitpunkt, das ist was Andy eben angesprochen hat, da ist es natürlich spätestens da ist es dann so, Voice-over-IP-Telefonie und da gibt es durchaus mehr Möglichkeiten, dass man mit anderer Software einfach zusätzliche Verschlüsselung nachrüstet und derartige Dinge tut.
Aber man sollte jetzt das nicht missverstehen, dass das auch der Fall ist. Also wenn wir sagen, das kann man, dann ist das halt, das erschließt Möglichkeiten. Aber im Moment laufen wir eigentlich in einem Szenario rum, wo die behördlichen, nachrichtendienstlichen und sonstigen Interessierten, die ein Budget dafür haben, sehr weitflächig, einen sehr großen Umfang Telekommunikationsdaten nicht nur abhören, im Sinne von mitlesen, ihnen Erfahrungen bringen, sondern vor allem speichern können. Weil man muss sehen, dass es wirklich dramatisch günstig ist, Telekommunikationsdaten auch in großem Umfang einfach wegzuspeichern. Eine 2 TB Festplatte kostet jetzt gerade noch 80 Euro netto. Und da kriegt man schon eine Menge drunter.
Es gibt ja, wenn wir auf dem Rechner kommunizieren, gibt es klare Ansagen von Leuten, die Plan haben, verschlüsselt euer Zeug, guckt zu, dass ihr anonym im Netz unterwegs seid. Gibt es eine einfache Anweisung für uns Handybenutzer, gerade bevor wir in der schönen neuen LTE Welt ankommen? Gibt es Hinweise zur Handynutzung, die ihr gibt?
Da kann man nicht viel hinweisen.
Man kann schon darauf hinweisen. Ich habe mich mal damit beschäftigt, wie in Botschaften, Telekommunikationssicherheit und so etwas realisiert wird. In bestimmten Besprechungsräumen werden Mobiltelefone vorher an der Garderobe abgegeben. Da gibt es da eigene Fächer für. Es gibt auch einen Service, der wenn ein Telefon klingelt, dass derjenige den Raum verlässt und in Ruhe draußen telefonieren kann. Aber wenn man Vertraulichkeit des Wortes will, dann sitzt man nicht in einem Raum, in dem Mobiltelefone sich befinden. Weil man muss ja auch mal sehen, diese Remotrojaner, die können unter Umständen nicht nur die Gespräche des Telefons bei einem Telefongespräch abhören, sondern auch einfach das Gerät in ein mikrofonsendendes Wanzenteil sozusagen verwandeln. Und das kann man schon als Hinweis verstehen. Es gibt auch im professionellen Bereich dann Jammer, mit dem man die Frequenzen plattlegt. Das ist allerdings unter Umständen nicht erlaubt, wie auch der Einsatz von aktiven Geräten, weil man die Frequenzen des Netzbetreiber stört. Und es gibt auch Verschlüsselungstelefonie und Methoden, um SMSen zu verschlüsseln und ähnliches.
Das ist ja noch relativ teuer, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Wir reden hier über Equipment, was man sich in der großen Industrie leistet, was man sich im wirklich staatlichen Bereich leistet, wo es um hohe Würdenträger und Geheimnisträger geht. Ich habe mal eine Zahl gehört, dass es in Deutschland insgesamt für sämtliche öffentliche Beschäftigte, also von Behörden egal welcher Art, nur 2000 Telefone gibt, die verschlüsseln. Also die, die diese End-zu-End-Verschlüsselung haben.
Woran liegt das eigentlich? Warum sind Telefone noch so rumgefragt? Warum sind Telefone, die verschlüsseln können, noch so teuer? Es gibt ja auf dem Rechner, man kann jetzt irgendwie einen PGP halten. Sonst lad ich mir runter, installiere ich fertig.
Ja, aber dann hast du noch das Problem, dass du nicht die Betriebssystemsicherheit im Griff hast. Das heißt, wenn du deine Nachricht verschlüsselst, dann hast du damit sichergestellt, dass auf dem Transportweg die Nachricht, die abgehört wird, dem Angreifer nichts nützt. Aber du hast damit nicht verhindert, dass ein Trojaner auf deinem Rechner die Nachrichten bevor sie verschlüsselt werden, während sie verschlüsselt werden. Und beim Mobilfunk ist genau das der kritische Punkt. Es gibt Software, die kannst du dir für die Smartphones teilweise sehr günstig im Netz herunterladen. Die machen aber nur Sparverschlüsse. Die sichern nicht dein Gerät gegen Angriffe ab. Und der künstliche Ansatz beides zu machen ist halt relativ viel Aufwand.
Okay, das ist klar. Das ist mir auch klar, sozusagen. Und das ist ja auch genau so, dass du sagen, auf deinem eigenen Rechner hast du genau immer das Problem. Aber was ich halt die Frage war, tatsächlich die eher, wenn ich wenigstens diesen einen Schritt gehen will.
Das ist eine Frage der Kontrolle und wie die Technik angelegt ist. Also wenn ich jetzt den PC anschaue, da ist die Hardware relativ offen spezifiziert. Man kann da beliebige Betriebssysteme drauf installieren. Ich kann da Linux, FreeBSD, Windows, Schlag mich tot, was auch immer darauf installieren. Und dann kann ich auf dem Betriebssystem beliebige Anwendungen installieren. Und die tun mit der Hardware in der Regel das, was ich halt irgendwie von ihr will oder was ich für Dinge drauf... Also zumindest sag ich mal, als Entwickler sollte ich da irgendwie oder als IT-Mensch sollte ich da in der Lage sein zu kontrollieren, was da passiert oder auch nicht. Auf den Mobiltelefonen ist es eben so, dass man in der Regel, zumindest bei Smartphones, hat man im Prinzip zwei kleine Computer in so einem Telefon drin. Das ist wie so ein Zweigehörn. Und der eine Teil... Es gibt da auch so Split-Brain-Syndrom. Also manchmal behauptet der eine Teil, das wäre so, und der andere denkt was anderes. Also der eine Teil dieses Telefons ist sozusagen das echte Telefon, das was mit dem Mobilfunknetz interagiert. Das ist der sogenannte Baseband-Prozessor. Und da drauf läuft halt Software, die entweder vom Telefonentwickler, aber meistens eigentlich von dem Chipsats-Entwickler kommt. Und dies extrem zugenagelt, da kann niemand irgendwas... Zumindest ist nicht vorgesehen, dass irgendjemand was zusätzlich installiert. Das heißt selbst auf einem Android oder was auch immer Telefon, wo ich tausend Dinge auf diesem Prozessor, wo eben das Android-System drauf läuft, nachinstallieren kann und verändern kann. Das betrifft überhaupt nicht diesen Baseband-Prozessor. Und da läuft diese ganze klassische Telefonie drauf. Und demnach sind sehr wenige Firmen, ich würde mal sagen ungefähr fünf auf der Welt, überhaupt in der Lage dort, diese Software zu verändern oder neue Funktionen dort einzubauen.
Also es ist quasi von mir ein Missverständnis gewesen, dass ich sage, wir haben noch diese krassen Smartphones, die alle tausend Sachen können, weil die gibt es zwar, aber der große Smartphone-Rechner, der drin ist, der hat mit diesem kleinen Telefonrechner, der völlig abgekapstelt ist, gar nichts mehr zu tun.
Nur eingeschränkt, da gibt es natürlich Interfaces dazwischen, aber es gibt noch eine weitere Dimension, die man erwähnen kann, nämlich, dass wenn man so ein Gerät absichern will, dann hast du A diesen Computerteil und dann hast du B diesen Baseband-Teil und es gibt halt auch Angriffe auf den Baseband. Das heißt, dass du ein Mobiltelefon, der zwar unabhängig von dem Betriebssystem, was da installiert ist, über die GSM-Schnittstelle, die es natürlich haben muss, weil sonst kannst du damit nicht telefonieren, angegriffen werden können, weil das ist wie gesagt auch nur ein Computer. Von Menschen programmiertes Software. Und auch da gibt es natürlich Exploits, also Programmierfehler, die sich ausnutzen lassen, um wiederum da weiter im Gerät irgendwas zu tun.
Nur um mal eine Größenordnung vielleicht zu bekommen, was da an Software läuft, das ist ein kleiner Telefon-Teil. Wir reden da inzwischen auch leicht über eine Komplexität von 3 bis 8 Millionen Zeilen Code, die da laufen, nur auf diesem Telefon-Teil.
Okay, ich möchte mir das nicht durchlesen. Hat sich schon mal jemand die Bühr gemacht, das zu Reverse-Engineeren, also rauszufinden, was da für Code läuft? Oder ist das sowieso öffentlich verfügbar?
Öffentlich verfügbar ist es nicht. Es gibt Leute, die da dran arbeiten. Und jetzt gerade im Hinblick auf diese Exploitbarkeit, also da Schadsoftware drauf zu installieren und eben Sicherheitslücken auszunutzen, da gab es auf mehreren Veranstaltungen letztes Jahr Vorträge von Ralf-Philipp Weinmann dazu. Der hat also sowohl bei aktuellen iPhones als auch bei Android-Telefonen jeweils Lücken gefunden, mit denen er in der Lage war, diese Telefone automatisch antworten zu lassen. Das heißt also, er schickt eine spezielle Nachricht über das GSM-Netz an das Telefon und danach der nächste eingehende Anruf, dann nimmt das Telefon sofort ab, ohne dass der Anwender irgendwie den Ich nehme mal den Anruf an-Knopf drücken muss.
Sehr schön, da haben wir heute wieder viel gelernt über Mobiltelefone. Ich breche es an dieser Stelle einfach mal ab, weil alles noch mal zusammenzufassen würde wahrscheinlich jetzt noch mal zwei Stunden dauern. Ich sage auf jeden Fall schon mal vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart. Ich würde auf jeden Fall noch fragen wollen, wenn man sich für das Thema jetzt weitergehen interessiert, was sind gute Ansatzpunkte im Netz, wo klicke ich, um mal sagen genauer dazu zu lesen?
Tja, wir könnten natürlich versuchen, noch mal eine kleine Linksammlung zur Sendung zusammenzustellen. Früher haben wir das auch mal geschafft bei Chaosradio Sendung. Was wir vielleicht jetzt noch tun könnten, wären die Stichworte für die Suchmaschine eurer Wahl zu geben.
Es gibt einfach mal Chaos Communication Congress Präsentationen nach GSM-Suchen oder derartigen Dingen. Es gab Vorträge zu Airprobe, zu Kraken. Das sind diese Abhörangriffe. Also rein passiv die Luftschnittstelle mit Lauschen von Carsten Nohl beispielsweise. Es gibt von Ralf-Philipp Weinmann eben diese Vorträge zu den Baseband-Exploits. Es gibt Vorträge zu OpenBTS und OpenBSC. Also wenn man einfach mal die IT-Security-Konferenz in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren abklappert, zu allem was mit GSM zu tun hat, da denke ich, ist man dann ganz gut informiert.
Okay, die Schlagworte habt ihr jetzt. Also könnt ihr noch mal googeln. Wer weiß, vielleicht schaffen ist ja sozusagen Seltsamer Heintel, wenn die noch mal so eine Linkliste zu bauen. Die würde dann ins Blog geworfen werden wahrscheinlich. Vicky, stimmt. Es gibt ja einen Vicky. Ihr könnt selber, wenn ihr jetzt und so weiter und so fort, ihr wisst, wie das funktioniert.
Haben wir nicht den Ausstieg aus der Vicky-Technologie beschlossen?
Also okay, das ist vielleicht eine Diskussion, die wir an eine andere Stelle führen. Das könnte auch länger dauern, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Traditionell macht ihr noch ein bisschen Werbung am Ende der Sendung. Ich habe gerüchteweise gehört, es steht ein runder Geburtstag an.
Ja, nun gut, es gibt ja zwei Ereignisse. Also Baus Todestag ist in vier Minuten, also wir sagen, ist morgen jetzt nicht so ein zehnmal, aber das ist natürlich eigentlich kein freudiges Ereignis. Trotzdem ist es auch anders, darüber nachzudenken, dass der Chaos Computer Club in diesem Jahr 30 Jahre wird. Das ist allerdings erst am 12. September. Gegründet ist er ja in den Räumen der Taz im Rahmen eines sogenannten 2-Watt-Kongresses. Und wir hatten schon mal den Versuch, die 20-jährige Geburtstagsfeier zu machen. Das war am 12. September 2001. Wir hatten eine Pressekonferenz am Vormittag des 11. September 2001, die die Veranstaltung ankündigen wollten. Wir hatten extra den Kongressalarm Alexanderplatz angemietet, die Ausstellungsfläche und so weiter. Aber irgendwie war am Nachmittag des 11. September 2001 ein anderes Thema, was uns völlig aus den Zeitungen verdrängt hat. Deswegen ist unsere 20-jährige Geburtstagsfeier so gut wie ausgefallen. Da ist keiner gekommen zur Ausstellung.
Und jetzt plant ihr keine 30-jährige, weil da möglicherweise wieder sowas passiert?
Ja, also soweit würde ich nicht gehen. Aber wir sind noch in der Konzeptionsphase. Wir haben noch kein echtes Konzept.
Okay, dann legen wir jetzt nicht weit über umgelegt. Also 30 Jahre auf jeden Fall. Und das Datum kommt noch her, war noch nicht. Manche Zeitungen erwecken einen anderen Eindruck. Außerdem gibt es den nächsten Camp, 10. bis 14. August. Im Sendungschat war gerade die Frage, wird es dort auch ein GSM-Netzwerk geben?
Ja, selbstverständlich. Auf den CTC-Veranstaltungen der letzten Jahre hatten wir eigentlich immer ein GSM-Netz zu Testzwecken. Das heißt, wir haben unser eigenes Mobilfunknetz. Da können die Leute sich einbuchen, können damit experimentieren, können damit spielen, können all die Dinge legal tun, die sie im echten Netz nie tun dürfen.
So, könnt ihr also hinfahren? Wo ist das nochmal?
In Finowood bei Eberswalde.
Alles klar. So, dann war's das. Diese Sendung wird es euch demnächst auch als Podcast geben. Sehr bald auf fritz.de und dann ein bisschen später auf chaosradio.ccc.de. So rum. Vielen Dank euch beiden nochmal für's Hiersein und Mitmachen. Gerne. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Und ich sag noch das, was ich immer an meiner Sendung sage, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.